My new to me, Toyota K S 858
arrived in mint condition.
It had been stored for quite some time,
but everything was there and it was
spotless.
Now, I expected the sponge bar to be flat,
but I didn't expect to find rust on the
needles.
There was no rust anywhere
else in the machine.
Apparently the sponge absorbed and held
moisture against the needles causing the
rust.
So why is this a problem?
Imagine forming stitches with yarn.
The rust prevents the yarn from slipping
smoothly along the shank of the needle and
forming this ditch properly.
I carefully removed each
needle from the needle bed.
Be sure to close the latch as you
slip the needle out of the channel.
On this machine, you really need to bend
the needle slightly to get it up and over
the back of the bed.
But don't worry.
These needles are designed to be used
with the lace carriage, so they're pretty
flexible.
Don't force them, but they
will bend enough to remove.
I soaked all of the needles in a jar,
partially filled with denatured alcohol,
and this removed most
of the rust by itself.
For those really stubborn spots, a bit
of fine sand paper or Emory cloth did the
trick.
This really took some
time, but it's so worth it.
After replacing the sponge bar, I now have
a practically mint machine to play with.